[Musique]
aujourd'hui on déchets guillaume
guillaume viala par l'ags bientôt
important n'a rien tout va porter voilà
bien alors guillaume vous le connaissez
on a fait plein plein de vidéos ensemble
et puis même guillaume il a fait des
vidéos sur la chaîne
c'était à bratislava c'était à londres
voilà et puis là aujourd'hui on est chez
toi voilà dans l'autre alors rires
aujourd'hui on est là pour la saline 9
16 challenge comme en chasse du fauteuil
c'est une chaise il gèle daily mail la
marque a aussi les fauteuils voilà ils
font très environ message est passé à ce
que vous l'avez donc aujourd'hui on va
installer une chaise de gaming la marque
c'est rect ok c'est une marque française
et s dont un des fondateurs principaux
est plus connu c'est julien tellouck
hockey et son frère paul
bon ok donc je te laisse prendre un peu
tous en main parce que c'est toi le
spécialiste dans le domaine moi je suis
moins spécialistes donc on a un gros
carton qui est là on le 30 ans
lumumbisme vous allez voir c'est assez
énorme
donc on ouvre on monte on compare avec
un ancien modèle et on compare avec une
marque concurrente est qui et qui a deux
trois ans on compare avec une marque
concurrente d'accord t'es quelques
années et puis voilà on s'assoit on est
heureux tout ça ça ne va pas comme ça
allez c'est ti par un joli bateau et
quand il était petit capot c'est ce qui
sépare 24
[Musique]
bon mais alors il ya maintenant tu ne
faisais pas il ya quatre vies c'est un
coup de tournevis à faire il s'est foutu
de notre gueule semblerait qu'ils
aillent un peu plus que ça comme pour
marquer un seul ace
j'ai des chevaux c'est guillaume moi je
vois là je fume je tiens la caméra
ah la vache ça c'est le moment que
j'aime le moins dans ce genre de choses
tu veux pas le garder le carton pour
faire une cabane
[Musique]
ça va trancher pas trop s'ils pensent
qu'ils bossent toi tu montres nous
explique francis démont des romans dont
elle a démonté vraiment toi c'est donc
là on a la mousse la galette de mousse
qui est quand même vachement épaisse on
a toute la mousse là qui arrive
directement et là vous avez des sangles
tapissier son doublé donc ils vont venir
vraiment jouer leur rôle d'un mortier de
confort de chaque côté fixé directement
sur la structure donc là je pense qu'en
termes de confort de le passer mais on
est pas mal de monde venu dans les
voiles donc là on a fini le montage
structure basse convoi rassembler avec
les roues il va nous rester le dossier
sas et les caches latéraux en général et
donc il nous reste pas mal de vis
le coussin également ouais donc
d'ailleurs en partie les boulots la côte
est
[Musique]
bon ça c'est le début on avait pas mal
est contrôle valider un côté bon blanchi
pour vous comme c'est le cas sur la
vidéo
en fait on est en train de faire un
petit ou de montage de s'y est pas mal
ça c'est sûr du montage de meubles comme
ça j'ai vraiment je me fais des
entreprises c'est à dire à quel point
j'ai à quel point je suis très mauvais
là dedans
à commencer par les vices du haut de mes
encore montalembert non mais ça va
faciliter la chose petites
recommandations vie c'est d'abord et
appliqué le clip ça la fin parce que
pour trouver le trou derrière c'est un
peu compliqué bravo elle tourne
bon bah dernier tape beaucoup ce à quoi
s'ajoutent aux fumeurs à les tests
commandés
alors du coup est ce qu'on retrouve en
fric donc aux accoudoirs qui se monte
qui se baissent latéral gauche 30 des
sages pression que ces voiles à envier
il n'y a aucune limite sur l'angulation
de ton choix tu peux vraiment avoir
l'angle d'accoudoirs que tu veux
par contre c'est l'énorme 180 degrés en
général il ya un système de veron pour
éviter de se péter la gueule je peux
dormir tu es vraiment à l'orangé ouais
mais là au niveau des jambes n'est pas
taillé terme il faudra un petit truc
ouais mais quand tu es en lan on l'a vu
mon avis il ya quelques semaines avec
[Musique]
le zii event justement rect était
sponsor il fournissait toutes les
chaises plusieurs joueurs dormait sur un
siège ça fait du bien bon du coup ne
reste une mallette monette une molette
pour le coup c'est vraiment la grosse
nouveauté la grosse wells et que la
grosse innovation
ça va être a priori le réglage de
laloubère tellement une voiture aurait
dit c'est ça il ya un système de
résistance plus ou moins fortes si on
tourne vers là on va avoir plus de
souplesse dans le dos et là sont ravis
de la résistance alors de robustesse
alors du coup on retrouve trois boutons
aux lettres quatre actions donc ce
bouton la safer avant arrière
ok sur la [ __ ] on va voir au bras du
côté intérieur
on va avoir gauche droite direct sur la
machine
on va avoir une ovulation à 45 degrés
dans dans tous les sens qu'on veut donc
en fait on a des accoudoirs 4 déc est
vraiment ce que tu veux avec vraiment il
n'ya pas de limite
chose très importante ouais la [ __ ]
d'en bas elle a un système de verrous
d'accord quand elle est tirée vers
l'extérieur et pas verrouillée quand
elle est rentrée elle est verrouillée
donc là fait voir la la c'est verrouillé
va se dérouler ce qui fait que quand je
m'allonge je pompe pas et là ça risque
d'être le highlight de ta vidéo
l'ag déverrouiller la [ __ ] ouais même
péter la gueule
ah oui là tu parles à rien tu vois je
vais pas continuer mais on en est là tu
vas tomber donc très important de
toujours verrouiller et de mètres vers
vers l'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est ouf c'est ouf le confort tu vois
le l'a6
c'est assez raide mais d'un autre côté
on est bien le dos dans la molette cette
année là la volt 1,6 ainsi comme moi les
bagnoles ça y est c'est vrai que là
franchement été bien direct j'ai une
suggestion
là je suis bien en plus en arrière
maintenant ce que je voudrais savoir le
regard un peu plus de vent donc ce qu'il
faudrait c'est juste mais permettre de
lever un peu ma tête comme ça tu vois
une commune celle de tes tirs un mauvais
tacle à claques une crémaillère
je suis calé alors à la côte et j'ai
peut-être perdre un petit peu en
ergonomie
je sais pas c'est un peu le seul truc
mais c'est vrai que sinon la 6e' père
ferme le doter pachon bien maintenue
bien c'est ouf ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure pour elle et que donc rect
propose des chaises gaming mais en fait
c'est décédé six chaises des chaises je
cherche c'est des chèches mais non c'est
pas des chèches c'est des chaises
c'est dur à dire c'est des chaises en
fait qui peuvent être utilisés par tous
ceux qui passent beaucoup de temps sur
les ordinateurs mac /
les gens s'en rendent pas compte mais à
partir du moment où vous avez une vraie
bonne chaise vous allez voir que ça va
vraiment changer votre vie laisse moi il
ya deux ans j'en ai acheté une way back
on va qu'on va montrer ouais je peux
juste plus passer en arrière en fait je
me tue le dos sur sur des sièges
standard désormais les d'époque chaise
banal et bien en fait ça s'appelle
chaise gaming nécessaires en grèce et
des chaises de bureautique banderas fait
sa chaise de bureautique confort en fait
voilà exactement
ok cool mais voilà on sait que dans les
bacs comme beaucoup j'ai craqué pour des
lices racer qui avait probablement une
des deux marques leaders du marché
le coussin arrière est amovible on a
juste cargo ebba on n'a pas de gauche
droite avant rien puisque tu veux il ya
juste les basques les accoudoirs on va
retrouver évidemment l'angulation mais
on est bloqué aux alentours des 120
degrés autres comme ça on n'est pas à
100 82 des pédaleurs unter descend
beaucoup fait pas déjà d'accord pour
après on n'a pas forcément besoin d'être
aussi bas on a un système de de manquer
pareille qu'ont expliqué de terre pour
éviter de se péter la gueule tous ceux
qui ont un siège gagné le savent
ce coup ça en fait
il finit toujours par arriver en bas
positionné au milieu à gauche à droite
ouais ils arrivent toujours en bas est
d'accord on toujours en permanence la dx
traceur est quand même vachement plus
que noté gainey avec le côté rouge avec
les courbes tandis que l'art est qd elle
fait effectivement beaucoup plus
polyvalente
dernier point qu'on a oublié de
mentionner c'est la matière on a un
simili cuir ou bien les risques c'est
que l'été ça risque de pas mal nous
faire transpirer à faire chauffer et là
on est sur du matériau respirant ou
avait du coup c'est beaucoup plus
agréable quand il fait chaud c'est
probablement un des éléments les plus
importants à prendre en compte quand
vous achetez une chaise les deux sont
très bien j'ai les deux systèmes entre
paris et toulouse
mais il est vrai que l'été est quand
même plus intéressant d'avoir un
matériel aspire peut-être qu'on peut
parler du prix donc là rect elle est
proposée à 366 9 euros nous avons déjà
tombé complètement amoureux d'elle madix
racer a va passer à la cave et marek
qu'elle va passer dans mon bureau
merci guillaume cool content que l'on
ait fait ça ensemble surtout merci à
rect julien paul difficile merci à vous
moi je vous connais pas encore tous mes
cousins d'ailleurs super sympa en tout
cas bon c'était cool en tout cas de
pouvoir faire ça ensemble
dites moi ce que vous en pensez je sais
pas si des chaises de gaming ce sont des
choses que vous avez que vous pourriez
avoir qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
jolie chaise de règles qu'elle est super
jolie un produit qui est vraiment bien
fait qui est pas trop connoté gaming et
qui prend coup je trouvais et thé gaming
d'ailleurs ces notes a raison tu as
raison mon produit de d'excellence en
fait c'est du premium
ok tu m'as fait dire une connerie c'est
soit merci beaucoup
si c'est bien qu'il c'est du gaming
c'est vrai mais visuellement pour
l'europe un tube on remercie guillaume
merci rect merci à vous la gent plus
nombreuses toujours plus nombreux ont
continué à faire des trucs ensemble et
puis pour l'instant mais voilà le
lâchait zeller guillaume sur plaisir à
la merci à vous vous dites moi ce que
vous pensez ce que les chaises de
confort comme s'achète de gaming ça vous
intéresse est ce que vous en avez
si oui dites moi laquelle vous avez en
bas et laquelle vous souhaiteriez revoir
et est ce que ce modèle direct pourrait
vous tentez vous marquez tout ça bien
évidemment bas et puis nous on va te
connecter on fait comme ça et vous allez
à bientôt
top